[La musique]
médecins infirmières infirmières préposées
nettoyage des supermarchés
soignants peut-être transporteurs de l'ordre
prêtres religieux volontaires et beaucoup mais
tant d'autres qui ont compressé ça
personne ne se sauve seul devant le
souffrance où la vérité se mesure
développement de nos peuples
nous découvrons et expérimentons la prière
sacerdotal de jésus que tous sont un
la seule chose dont nous ne sommes pas assez
seule
[La musique]
seuls nous coulons nous avons besoin du
dames comme les anciens marins de la
étoiles
nous invitons Jésus dans nos barques
les vies délivrent aux épouses nos peurs
afin qu'il puisse les vaincre comme disciples
nous en ferons l'expérience avec lui à bord non
il fait naufrage
parce que c'est la force de dieu jouera
le bien tout ce qui nous arrive
monsieur dit bien le monde
salue les corps et réconforte les cœurs
on demande de ne pas avoir peur mais le
notre foi est faible seigneur que nous sommes
craintif
mais vous, monsieur, ne vous laissez pas à la merci
de la tempête
[La musique]